Fisher: I'm Jeff Fisher,
and this is a short
introductory video
on using the .Net Client Library
Google Data APIs.
Let's get started.
First, you have to download
the SDK
from our code.google.com page
at this URL.
I've already downloaded the SDK,
so let's install it.
For this demo, I'm using
Microsoft Visual C#
2008 Express Edition,
which is free
and a good way to get started.
However, the SDK assumes
we're using Visual Studio 2005,
so we have to copy
the Project Templates.
If you're using
Visual Studio 2005,
you don't have to do this step.
Now that we've done that,
we can go ahead
and open Visual Studio.
Since we have these Templates,
printing a new project is easy.
First go to New Project.
We can create
a Google Picasa project
with one click.
This creates a new blank project
with some code for us.
It also creates a dialogue box
for the user to log in.
If you look at the code
behind this,
we first discuss some
of the high level principles
of our Client Library.
The Client Library is organized
into the following components.
There is the Service Class,
which deals with the connection
to the API.
There are Query Classes
which allow us to construct
particular queries
against the API.
And there are also
Feed and Entry Classes
that contain the data model.
In this simple example,
we first create
a new service class.
Then we get our log-in
information
from the form provided
by the template.
And then we're able to create
a new AlbumQuery.
Then we get back a feed
of all the users' albums.
Looping through this feed
gives us a number of entries
which contain information
about each album
that the user has.
We are then able to update
a GUI element
with information
about these albums
and display it to the user.
Let's run this example.
First I have to log in.
And now you can see each
of the albums in my test account
along with the number of photos
that are in each album.
That's a simple way
to get started.
But perhaps you want a more
detailed code example to copy.
For that, we can go
into the SDK directory
in our start menu
and open up the Sample solution.
Again,
since we're using 2008,
we have to quickly convert
the existing solution.
Now that we've done that,
we can see that there are
a number of samples
provided for us.
The first one I'd like to show
is the Photo Browser.
This is an advanced form
of the demo that we saw earlier.
Again, we have to log in.
Again, we see the list
of albums,
but this time,
we can see the album cover
and double-click to see
each photo inside of the album.
All of this code
is open source
and available for you to use
in your own applications.
One other sample
I'd like to show you
is the DocList Uploader.
Go ahead and set this
as a StartUp Project.
This sample allows us to quickly
log in to Google Docs...
See our existing Docs,
open them,
and also upload new ones
by dragging and dropping.
Again, this sample
is Open Source,
and you can see
all of the code.
Now that we've gone through
some of the samples
and gotten you started
compiling your own application,
let's talk about some of
the resources that are available
to help you develop.
All of our resources
are available
on code.google.com
starting at the Project Page
of the .net Client Library.
Besides downloading the SDK,
you can also view
the documentation.
The documentation includes
a Javadoc style reference
for all of the classes,
members, constructors...
and objects used
in the Client Library.
We also have a number
of Developer Guides
for each particular API
that walk you through
each operation
that can be performed.
Lastly, if you have
any questions,
we have a discussion group
available
for you to ask any questions,
concerns,
or request any features that
are not currently available.
Thanks for watching this video.
I hope that you'll create
some interesting applications
and share them with us.